stefan
i want to know what do you consider to
be a theory of everything the reason i
ask this is when i asked so well some
people say well it needs to incorporate
consciousness or needs to explain the
origins of the universe some people just
unify gravity in the standard model
what does the theory of everything mean
to you
it's a really good question um
well i mean i have um my ambitions now
are
um
i would say that for example if string
theory
um
was able to
provide
like as a solution and a you know that
meets the standard of what a solution is
in string theory that gives us back
say something
like like an early like at the very
least an early universe scenario that is
consistent with observation
um
maybe it's inflation maybe it's an
alternative to inflation
i would literally say that string theory
therefore
modulo
it's difficulty and tell me why that
solution is preferred over other
solutions would be a fear of everything
all right uh um and then i would and
then i would add about you know the more
like the questions of like okay higher
level organizational properties of
matter
including life and including
consciousness i have some thoughts about
that too but i would say that um you
know at this level i would call that a
theory of everything so it sounds like
that's been a a common thread throughout
your entire career because around 2000
2001 or so but you've been working at it
probably in 2000. you had the inflation
of the d brain debris annihilation
and that seemed at least seemed to
produce something that looks akin to the
big bang and i believe you used some
data to show
i'm not sure if you
if you made a prediction and you showed
how it matches with prediction i'm not
sure about that but either way that
sounds like a through line
yeah so um
i was trained as a string cosmologist
meaning that
you know someone that knows both string
theory and enough cosmology enough of
each okay but certainly not a master of
either
um
to
because back then this was the year 2000
1999 2000 the call was um
can we
some people some people felt string
theory wasn't developed enough some of
us felt it was developed enough to then
ask questions of can we reproduce
something like cosmic inflation so i
went to my first postdoc trying to do
that um and that was my take on how to
do that so i guess the fact that it was
published meant that you know it met
some standards um
and but one of the things it did do was
it opened the floodgates for other
string theorists and i certainly wasn't
the first and the only one
um
but anyway open the floodgates for
others to then
improve or develop different ideas but
similar
um ideas you know with string theory
that somehow these d brains are playing
some role
in um
and describing the early universe and
four dimensions out of ten dimensions
did you do that work at ubc
very good um i
i spent a lot of my time thinking about
the idea when i was at ubc as a grad
student
but then i
really did it when i was a postdoc at
imperial college in london